good news bad news uh one it's cancer
it's called lymphoma it's the cancer of
the lymphatic system
um and the good news is is something
called Hodgkin's lymphoma it's the most
treatable like one of the most treatable
cancers Hank Green reveals he's been
diagnosed with cancer so there have been
a bunch of times over the last
few weeks when this has become more and
more real sharing the news with fans in
an emotional message on YouTube so I uh
noticed that my lymph nodes were big I
talked to my doctor she says probably
nothing will send you in for an
ultrasound got an ultrasound the attack
and the ultrasound room was like I'm
gonna go get a doctor
and that's not what you want to have
happen the best-selling author says
there's a treatment plan in motion but
admits it will be a difficult Journey
from here the goal is cure the procedure
to get there is fairly well known if
unpleasant but the treatment is a fairly
well established like system of
chemotherapies which I'm going to start
very soon
um not looking really forward to it but
I'm looking forward to starting on the
path Hank's brother John Green is also
an author best known for The Fault in
Our Stars oblivion's inevitable and if
that scares you then I suggest you
ignore it if I had to describe the Fault
in Our Stars in one word hopeful on
Twitter John calls his brother my
closest collaborator oldest friend and
my absolute hero I want to introduce you
first to Hank Green of the vlogbrothers
hey great to see you President Obama for
over a decade Hank and John have been
influential voices on the internet
starting with their YouTube channel
vlogbrothers hi there this is John Green
and I'm Hank Green before moving into
education-based content it's pretty much
the most complicated molecule that
exists according to Hank's website their
videos are used in nearly every High
School in the country racking up more
than 2 billion views I really needed
friends in the last few weeks and I've
been very grateful to have them I felt
very lucky to have great friends and
family uh around to
joke with and hang with and support me
uh and give me the Good Vibes back in
John's message he Echoes his brother's
gratitude amid their family's crisis
thank you for loving him as I do and
supporting us and each other in a tough
time what am I gonna make I don't know
am I gonna make vlogbrothers videos am I
going to make dear Hank and John am I
going to make Sideshow and I'm going to
make tangents like I do just kind of
want to say it out loud that like I want
to be like fun goofy Science Guy
not like struggling with anxiety cancer
guy
um and and like you know you can be both
[Music]